welcome to the program Donald Trump's
second muslim-majority country
immigration ban has already lost the
court battle as a reminder Donald Trump
passed the first version it was stayed
by a Washington Court the stay was
upheld in the appeals process that first
Muslim majority country immigration ban
was effectively destroyed then Donald
Trump came out with his second band
which reduced the number of countries on
the list from seven to six it exempted
green card holders and some others
already in process made a few other
changes but one of the very clear parts
of this new law is no refugees certainly
from the country of Syria and we already
have just days after this new band was
put out there US District Judge William
conri who just on Friday blocked
president Trump's administration from
enforcing the new travel ban against the
particular Syrian family looking to
escape war-torn Syria by fleeing to
Wisconsin now to be super clear this
decision from Judge Connelly doesn't
block the entire travel ban it is still
enforced as written for now as of five
minutes ago things can change very
quickly though but it's just borrowing
the enforcement of the ban against this
particular family and there are many
exemptions and waivers in this new band
including some that actually give
individual consular offices the
flexibility to decide on particular
cases something that was not the case
with travel travel van bit travel ban
version number one meanwhile though and
this is where you know the fundamental
nature of this is just completely and
totally backwards meanwhile as I told
you recently Donald Trump has reversed
an Obama era order which has led to
increased weapons sales to Saudi Arabia
which is actually the primary source
country for 911 attackers and you really
need to understand this because it seems
understandably insane
main countries that aren't on the ban
list actually had nationals who attacked
the US on US soil including during 911
many of those countries make Donald
Trump and his billionaire and multi
multi-millionaire supporters lots and
lots of money so Donald Trump is sort of
between a rock and a hard place or
between Iraq and a hard place as I came
up with that on my own I know Pat
doesn't believe that but I did come up
with that on my own you can't sort of
jeopardize your business buddies but you
need to do something since you made that
promise during your campaign so what do
you do you create a muslim-majority
country immigration band but you only
include the countries on that list that
aren't going to upset your supporters
we're selling weapons to the home
country of the plurality of 911
attackers and we're saying that this is
a plan Pat that is going to make a safer
we need to look at geopolitics we need
to look at the military-industrial
complex and we need to understand the
kleptocracy don't we to understand what
it is what's going on here I mean I
think herein lies the problem of having
an immigration band based off of
something like country of origin really
if we're going to up our vetting
procedures we should look more into if
they have a criminal history or how
badly they need to come here this may
appeal to the base of having a blanket
statement across the six countries but
it just opens up the possibility is that
a family from Syria who absolutely needs
to come here and seek refuge are just
forgotten about even the Department of
Homeland Security said that just using
country of origin as a basis for
determining whether an individual might
present or does present a risk a safety
risk a national security risk of the
United States it's not actually a good
way to do it Donald Trump was given that
report from DHS rejected it because it
didn't say what he wanted it to say if
there was a reason to think that a band
like this made a safer then the
conversation about legality becomes the
primary conversation
hey this will definitely keep us safer
is it legal is it moral is it ethical
right and I'm not saying that I would I
would be in favor of it in that case I'm
just saying that would be the primary
topic of conversation since the
countries on the list haven't actually
had Nationals come to the United States
and attack us this is not only a
questionable legality it doesn't appear
to make us safer while we're at it by
the way we should also be looking at the
TSA super closely you have minimally
trained security screeners who when
tested internally recently allowed
ninety-five percent of banned items
through okay look up that study we
talked about it months ago when it
happened 19 out of 20 banned items were
successfully brought through TSA
security checkpoints during an internal
test of the systems again how do we
justify these non-functional solutions
and particularly how are we going to
make good decisions when we get a report
from the Department of Homeland Security
saying this is not an effective means of
increasing national security and
preventing terror and the president and
his associates say yeah that's not the
report that we asked for it doesn't say
what we wanted to say incredibly
disturbing not only from a legal and
moral perspective but also from a purely
pragmatic perspective in terms of
keeping Americans safe